Good morning, John.
As I make this video, there are lots of people killing lots of people in France; in Paris.
It is impossible for me to think about anything except for that thing;
and it is
also impossible for me to have any -
anything except feelings. Like, there's a time for analysis, there's a time for
thinking, there's a time for trying to figure out why people... are the way they are.
Uh... where... behaviours originate. But, this is
not that time.
It is just.. emotions. It is just sad,
fear, anger.
I have a friend who's in Paris right now. He hasn't.. tweeted anybody;
he hasn't done anything on social media, so it's just terrifying.
It is just a time for.. feeling. Umm.. and I know that we all want to analyze, now we are
living that kind of world where we want to immediately take our worldview and say:
"If only we had been the way we
should have been, the way that I wish the world were,
this wouldn't have happened."
That's going to be flawed forever. But it is especially flawed right now.
And I think the thing to feel is.. wha- like, whatever it is we should feel.
Like, you know, I think if the response is to disengage, that is appropriate.
If your response is to stare at live feeds from Twitter and Reddit, that is appropriate.
If your response is to just be terrified for your friends, your family,
yourself, or just people, because we are all people, that is appropriate.
There's nothing useful I could say.
There's you know, like
"Hatred is not the correct response to hatred"..?
I don't know...
"The world is broken,
but hope is not crazy"..?
Yeah..?
That's good, that was a John Green one.
It`s hard enough to think about the effects this kinda have like, globally and
on Europe..
It's hard not to
think about the effect that this is gonna have like globally and..and on Europe; but I just think like, right
now, I'm.. I want to think about the people... who risked their lives to save people.. and to help
people. I want to think about the people who've lost people. And I want to think about the people who've been lost. I think that's the thing to think about.
That is the - yeah...
John, I will see you on Monday.